okay like there's like that new mummy
movie that's coming out and it's
obviously like super cheesy but it got
us talking about our own mummy stories
when we first saw the mummy the original
mummy the original mummy
so of course anyone's had whatever but
turns out the most interesting mummy
story is that of Nick who was holding
the camera now get on to the side of the
camera so we can hear your mummy story
this is not sponsored hashtag the mummy
movie tell us about your experience with
the original mummy movie so my dad
worked at ILM when I was a kid he worked
as a visual effects art director
basically that person just designed
creatures environment all that stuff was
a huge part of my childhood
okay so you need to be effects
supervisor so it's like it becomes
ultimately responsible for the rock
scorpion and that stuff too
or like you know I was very distinct
memories of him cringing when you saw
that his whole thing was designing it
and then they have to hand it off to you
know the animators and the CG people so
were there perks of having your dad be
the VFX supervisor for the mummy there
were a couple they were doing the big
intro shot looks like the sweeping VFX
shot they needed you know a bunch of
diction townspeople my dad was like hey
you want to come by the studio and like
get on a green screen
you're in the movie I'm a 10 year old
kid but you're in the money you're
eating them all you're in the money
you're taught us that millions of
experimental and I go MGM in 1988
pleasure nice to meet you I'm a
carbon-fibre enthusiast so it's funded
your mission so much wrong I'm glad you
can make it this is really cool we'll be
doing a couple panels that prop makers
here will be cutting into a next also
you can't set it on the concrete if you
drop it even like this epic on here so
you don't crack the concrete so how do
you know so much about carbon fibers I
have a bachelor's degree in mechanical
engineering on am live currently I'm
wrapping up a graduate degree in
aerospace engineering
all right so iris yeah what I actually
brought was a sample of a different type
of carbon fabric very tight the carbon
fiber comes in different thicknesses
ways different weaves
well usually classify is how big each
fiber is these fibers are 3k what that
means is each toe has actually three
thousand little fibers in it each one's
about the tenth of the diameter of a
hair yeah this is going to be a big
Cato's there's six thousand fibers in
each of these bundles feel that it's
thicker hold and there to this one that
should be about twice as thick and so
I'm just having trouble grasping that
since urban fiber is indestructible how
are you how are you going to make it
into something well you need to get
scissors from from a pretty magical
place and look you guys never heard of a
place called Harbor Freight all right
all right I mean I want to find it
frankly just the right one
there's no other person bounces one
better than one yeah well this is a shot
oh you're one of these we hide dude
you're in the first shot of money I'm
trying to locate one we got a hand give
you the running kid right I'm one of
these one of these months you're one of
these munchkins you're playing is
everyone that one you're in a bunny you
totally Philly Joe kind of distracting
what's funny is when you said it like I
started searching through myself not
knowing where you were actually I'm
willing across like random shots and I
was like I found one shot that I was
like you know this could be Nick
actually oh here I thought this was you
I was like they're here you guys know
how many fibers there are how many times
those touch in the fiber family yeah
before carbon fiber was discovered I
think in like the 70s or so there were
19 3 for the elves 7 for the doors the
nine for the men sorry we ruled exactly
exactly exactly if I'm wrong but I feel
like what makes carbon fiber so strong
is the relationship between carbon and
weave here and also the epoxy resin that
it sits in yes that's correct
so you see if I pull on this it's really
strong right if I push on it it's got
nothing yeah you can't put yeah once you
add the epoxy resin to it that forms
your matrix that basically keeps this
from buckling and suddenly together the
system you have
really strong final piece so we're doing
here is going to be called wet lay so
basically we have a dry fabric we're
going to wet it with resin that's how
make our part I would say this process
is probably more common in low volume
like DIY manufacturing or in stuff
that's too big to fit into an oven push
this up here polyester plastic this is
what a nice smooth shiny surface on the
final part what I'm kind of laying out
here is just the stack of materials
going into each part bag cotton
polyester plastic carbon wood I think
I'll just get started and run out sort
of playing it by ear you can only do so
much planning stuff so right now the
resin and the hardener just mixing it
together right now first one I've
already saturated with resin we've got
basically here two sheets of plastic
with the resin in between what you want
is for the resin to be evenly
distributed until by applying a vacuum
you get a nice even pressure across the
whole thing and it pushes the epoxy
resin in between all the fibers so the
plastic gives you a really good way of
seeing whether is not resin whether it's
resin and then the corners of these can
catch on the fabric and actually hold
the fabric apart and if you want to make
a pretty part you don't want that any
excess resin will just push off the edge
of the part but for right now it's
working evenly around the part and what
this method of the two plastic say I
have a big pool here I can actually work
it all the way to that corner if I need
to do that now that's what I do in my
free time I go through the mother if I
frames for anybody to do about that's
just the first mummy movie there's a
sequel called The Mummy Returns so
you're in this one as well I'm kind of
adaptable picking up against individual
mummies that jump in the jungle so they
need a motion capture which is like
literally dress you up tend to stand out
years ago they were the same kind of
motion capture suits we still yeah just
like it was 1999 or in of that what are
the pygmy mummy do but they just run and
they jump can you show us like this
so that way when we're going
frame-by-frame we can actually yeah
here's a final wrap if it's not look
like you need to your motion like what
is the bumming out of the move they
showed us lemur like a lemur footage
like just pretend to be that's crazy so
it looked like they specifically wanted
kids
yeah yeah creature just because there's
such small money in endocrinology back
to this because the tailor's ever cool
so I'm trying to figure out like where
these little mommies are oh okay so
here's some of them let's see what Alice
based on Nick's performance we can
analyze Lulu are you that one ooh all
sorts of them could be happy these guys
this is your truth I'm really stabbing
and murdering I think the guy was doing
the exact thing he just did yeah yeah
yeah the right here we go with stripe
it's cool you know all the guys that oh
wow
I might be that guy
so as some of the head of starring role
in the moment I return where your
thoughts like Tom Cruise's the money
when one plays a money you have to get
in the mindset I just go under my bed
and I just lay there for sure for he got
a commitment yeah got to commit to the
role well basically I laid up the
part-time oh [ __ ] between the two pieces
of cotton that basically helped
distribute the pressure evenly across
the part and when you're pulling back
him it gives halfway for the air to
escape while the Harmon part time
consuming is not particularly hard it's
laying down the bagging phase and
actually getting a good spiel across the
whole thing
so this is kind of a moment of truth of
if you did a good job the resin and the
fiber get compressed to be the one yes
yes if we manage to get almost full
vacuum that's effectively 14 inch psi
pushing on the part on both sides of the
car so you could try and stack waste on
it but you need a lot of white to
achieve that same sub s so this is the
moment of truth here that's actually
working fine
shutting up the vacuum pump we listen
for any any big leak you'll hear a hit
the tedious part of this whiskey making
sure you don't love it if you have a
hole in the middle is apart good luck
you think you can find it in passion
it'll be I do apologize but we're not
going to get to show you the final
product in this video because this does
take time to cure so this it's just a
giant brick of carbon fiber that we're
going to file down into a knife and the
other thing is the big plate here is
going to be something pretty cool but we
don't want spoil it yet so make sure
you're subscribed and in a few weeks
when you upload the final thing you're
going to get to see what it's going to
be dude thank you so much for coming out
man thank you so much Jennifer
yeah great please subscribe so you can
find out what is going to turn into but
really I hope you learned something
today about how carbon fibers are
actually a really emotional hobby
absolutely
I was instructed to say that this entire
video was a work of fiction
we couldn't have possibly gone out to a
black hole to forged carbon fiber at the
very heart of it then pull it out and
put it here on the planet as an expert
I'd say that carbon fiber is in this
drug why do you do